you never tried to have a really good
relationship with these other people
and that's the reason i'm pissed off
man just the knife in the kidneys over
all these years
sacrifices that i made
to love you
[Music]
sister wife star cody brown lashing out
over his wife christine's decision to
leave their plural marriage
nobody is a prisoner here if if this
isn't working for you
you know there's five of us very five
different thinking adults who are trying
to raise kids together have a family
together
and we don't see eye to eye on all
things and the not seeing eye to eye
part is front and center in the show's
new season as the family deals with cody
and christine's relationship coming to
an end and nobody's taking it well i
feel like it's more of an inevitability
coming instead of a let's try to work
this out i felt like that christine was
more than a sister wife i felt like that
she was a friend for a lot of years i'm
not ready for christine to leave
hang on with me okay
i am
we have to rebuild
the two ended their 25-year spiritual
marriage in november and last season
fans saw the first signs the
relationship was crumbling i'm not
okay with that
i'm not okay with staying in a marriage
where there's no intimacy that's not a
real marriage the couple's relationship
was strained by the coven 19 pandemic
which caused friction about where to
live
i really like living separate i like my
own space i like my own autonomy i feel
like i like me better now as and i just
feel like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence
we've had some misunderstandings because
of covid
uh where
i mean
any relationship
uh okay
plural for marriage to put a little
little more pressure on a relationship
and this season cove is still a major
issue but christine's deeper reasons for
leaving the marriage become clearer
i feel like to cody robin's more
important it's been heartbreaking being
your wife
for years i agreed to be a sister wife
but i agreed to be an equal
wife i've decided to leave i'm gonna
leave cody and that news leads to this
explosive moment with christine her
sister wives robin mary janelle and of
course cody you never tried to have
really good relationship with these
other people
and that's the reason i'm pissed off
man
yeah and it's something cody has said
he's dealt with before it doesn't just
require me
to make this relationship work it
requires them to and if one wife reaches
out to another wife and tries to develop
a friendship and
and gets
gets rejected in that
that makes it very hard for me to be
between them
as they
are not
um
in a good place
just months before the split the reality
star talked about the difficulty of
making multiple marriages work and why
divorce is never an option i'm not in a
place where i i say hey to a wife i'm
leaving you that's just never going to
happen
um it's just not you know
if if our relationship isn't good then
we either figure out how to work it out
or or whatever i don't even know what
that looks like we've been doing
counseling for
seven years you know
so
we don't allow the d word in the house
well not out of my mouth necessarily
[Music]